Musik Ich habe am letzten Mal gesagt, der Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist, dass man jede Folge ein bisschen anders aufnimmt. Und heute, glaube ich, ist uns was ganz Besonderes gelungen. Und zwar sind wir tatsächlich verbunden telefonisch heute mal, nicht per Skype oder irgend so neumodischen Kram. Nein, wir haben uns für das gute alte Faxgerät entschieden. Wir sind heute völlig elektronisch per Funk Funk verbunden. Das ist ganz fantastisch. Ja, und warum ist das so? Es hätte ja auch anders funktionieren können, weil wir exakt die gleichen Aufnahmebedingungen haben wie noch vor einer Woche, wo es sehr gut funktioniert hat, komischerweise, und jetzt haben wir keine Internetverbindung. Florentins Router ist anscheinend nicht mehr vorhanden, nicht mehr existent. Wir haben keine Internetverbindung mehr und Florentin hat irgendwie so einen Delay von fünf Minuten gehabt. War irgendwie lustig, hätte auch was gehabt, so eine Mystery-Folge, wo der Zuschauer dann irgendwie im Nachhinein dechiffrieren muss, was wir da gesagt haben. Ich fände es auch mal gut, wenn wir unsere Spuren komplett unabhängig voneinander aufnehmen würden und dann einfach zusammenfügen würden, wo man immer so Pausen lässt für den anderen zum Reden und der andere muss das dann irgendwie spüren, wann er was zu sagen hat. Fände ich sehr, sehr gut. Ja, oder man veröffentlicht jede Spur als eine Folge, als eine separate Folge, dann hat man nur einen Reden. Bei mir ist das sehr viel ... Bei einem anderen Podcast, den ich mal hatte, war es tatsächlich so, dass ich am Ende aus ... Also jeder speichert ja seine eigene Spur auf seinem eigenen Rechner und dann werden die zusammengeführt. Und bei einem anderen Podcast war es so, dass ich aus Versehen meine Spur gelöscht habe und dann habe ich versucht, die Folge trotzdem noch zu retten, indem ich einfach mir die Spur des anderen anhöre und dann sozusagen in die Lücken irgendwas reinrede, so was ich da auch gesagt habe. Und es hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Das ist ja eine grossartige Idee. Grossartig, ja. Das ist ja eine richtig grossartige Idee. Da sollten wir mal einen Test machen. Wird jeder von uns mal eine Folge auf und lässt Lücken mit so ganz absurden Themen wechseln, zwischen den Lücken und der andere muss dann reinlabern. Und ich habe tatsächlich häufiger Folgen gelöscht. Und einmal hatten wir eine Folge mit Soundeffekten und ich habe alles gelöscht, außer die Spur der Soundeffekte und dann haben wir eine neue Folge aufgenommen und haben einfach die alten Soundeffekte irgendwie boing, buuuu, klatschen und so drin gelassen, an völlig unpassenden Momenten, aber es war fantastisch. Ja, das glaube ich. Aber dieses Konzept der vor aufgezeichneten Nummer, die man da dazuspricht, finde ich sehr fantastisch. Ein befreundeter Schauspielkollege hat immer erzählt davon, dass jemand bei einer Schauspielschulen-Aufnahmeprüfung, wollte er diesen Filmnachspielen nicht auflegen mit Colin Farrell. Und da geht es ja darum, dass jemand in der Telefonzelle steht und mit jemandem spricht, den man nie sieht. Und um das darzustellen, hat er eben Aufnahmen aus dem Film mitgebracht und hat die dann abgespielt, sozusagen vom Tonband und hat dann zwischendrin seine eigene Textteile gesprochen als Colin Farrell.
Und innerhalb von wenigen Dialogzeiten muss es so gewesen sein, dass es komplett asynchron war und es überhaupt nicht mehr zusammengepasst hat und einfach kläglich gescheitert ist.
Aber ich finde das so schade, die Vorstellung des ambitionierten Schauspielstudents so, ja, ich mache mal was Besonderes, die sehen jeden Tag irgendwie Faust und Gretchen und ich mache was Neues und er scheitert einfach von vorne bis hinten. Das ist aber eine gute Idee eigentlich. Total. Das ist eine gute Idee, wenn man keinen Spielpartner hat, einfach in die Lücken reinreden, das ist eine sehr gute Sache. Wir haben heute keine Themen. Ja, dann stelle ich dir doch mal eine Frage. Nein, das wollen wir jetzt nicht, dann werde ich wieder 30 Sekunden lang schweigen und hoffen,
dass irgendwer in ein Zimmer kommt und anfängt für mich zu reden.
Nein, aber hast du dir denn Sachen überlegt für die Folge?
Nein. Also, muss ich das in die Hand nehmen,
weil ich habe mir ein paar Sachen überlegt.
Ach, ist das so? Ja.
Ja, und los? Ja, aber halt ein Huttie.
Und zwar, ich bin ja, sage ich mal, ein gesellschaftlicher Beobachter. Also gerade in der Zwischenmenschlichkeit ergeben sich für mich Goldgruben, die ich auslöffle. Und es ist mir erst aufgefallen, es gibt manche Fragen, auf die es keine richtigen Antworten gibt. Also gewisse Dinge, die man gefragt wird, auf die man nicht richtig antworten kann. Und zwar, ich eröffne einfach mal den Themenbereich Kieferorthopäden. So, hattest du denn jemals eine Zahnspange? Ja, in der Tat, habe ich in der vierten Klasse glaube ich schon bekommen, relativ früh oder und hatte ja abends ja noch, nee, oder eher noch, auf der weiterführenden Schule habe ich die schon losbekommen. Und da hatte ich dann wunderschöne Zähne und habe alle ausgelacht, die noch mit Zahnsparen rumliefen. Das weiß ich noch.
Und ich finde, Kieferorthopäde ist immer so dieses Zwischenfeld zwischen Kindheit und Erwachsenenleben, weil oft sind Kieferorthopäden Praxen so eingerichtet, dass sie attraktiv sind für Kinder und viele der Anwendungsbereiche und Materialien sind auf Kinder zugeschnitten. Und es ist immer ein bisschen seltsam, wenn man als Erwachsener dann dahingeht und dann sozusagen Fragmente dieser alten kindlichen Lebenssicht noch mal vor Augen gehalten will. Zum Beispiel gibt es so diese Technik, dass so Abdrücke von deinen Zähnen gemacht werden,
indem du irgendeine riesige, wahnsinnig viel Masse, irgendwie so eine Art Lehm oder Knete-Kram in deinen Mund kriegst und es ist unglaublich unangenehm und
würgelreflex und furchtbar und dann beisst du da drauf und dann wird es hart und so weiter. Hat bestimmt schon mal jemand wieder gemacht.
Und bei mir war es dann so, da sitze ich dann in dem Stuhl und dann kommt die, ja wir machen jetzt diesen Abdruck, welche Geschmacksrichtung hätten sie denn gerne? Ja genau. So, und das ist eine der Fragen, wo ich mir denke, da gibt es eigentlich keine richtige Antwort drauf, weil die einzige richtige Antwort als Erwachsener muss sein, ist mir egal. Eigentlich darf man in der Situation keine Präferenz haben, weil was ist denn das für eine seltsame Präferenz, das ist genauso wie dein Autoreifen, was soll der für einen Geschmack haben, es muss dir eigentlich als Erwachsener egal sein. Du darfst eigentlich in gewissen Dingen keinen Genuss verspüren. Und was war deine Antwort? Erdbeere.
Im Erwachsenenleben ist es eigentlich nicht so wie bei Kindern, wo man versucht, jeden Teil, also Medizin schmeckt dann gut und du hast dann irgendwie ein Pflaster, wo irgendwelche lustigen Figuren drauf sind, aber als Erwachsener ist das eigentlich sehr strange. Und deswegen habe ich, dachte ich mir, meine einzige Chance ist es, ich nenne eine Geschmacksrichtung, die sie bestimmt nicht haben.
Und dann, weil dann zählt sie gewisse Geschmacksrichtungen auf und dann kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr sagen, es ist mir egal. Weil wenn sie gesagt haben, ja, Cola, Kirsche, Himbeer, Multivitamin, kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr sagen, es ist mir egal. Weil wenn sie gesagt haben, ja Cola, Kirsche, Himbeer, Multivitamin, kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr sagen, es ist mir egal, weil dann kommt sie sich dämlich vor. Genau, weil sie schon diese Anstrengung übernommen hat, dir alles aufzuzählen. Da darfst du nicht mehr sagen, ist mir egal, dann musst du sagen, Erdbeere, Banane, Kirsche. Ja, aber irgendwie findest du nicht auch, dass dieser Prozess des Entscheidens, was man lieber mag, irgendwie was sehr Persönliches ist?
Ist total kindlich. Aber auch was Persönliches. Ach so, so gut verstehe ich. Ich weiß nicht, jemandem dabei zuzuschauen, wie er sich für etwas entscheidet, finde ich, ist etwas sehr Persönliches und mir auch relativ unangenehm, vor allem in so einer komischen Situation. Du kriegst ja auch dann nicht irgendwie gesagt, ja, wir haben hier zum Beispiel Kirsche und Banane, sondern die haben dann sowas wie Schlumpfeisgeschmack. Ja, genau. Schlumpf, Pinocchio. Kaugummi. So was haben die dann halt. Das ist ja nichts, wo man sagt, ja, gerne, boah, ich liebe Bananen, nehmen wir halt Banane. Das sind ja nicht solche Geschmacksrichtungen. Das ist ja der Scheiss.
Aber es ist so lustig, dass du genau Banane sagst, weil ich habe auch genau gesagt, Banane, in der Annahme, sie haben keine Banane, weil Banane ist wirklich einer meiner Lieblingsgeschmäcker. Banane ist wahr aus. Banane. Und ich habe gesagt, Banane ist ja okay. Und das Problem war gelöst. Und das war so strange, weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es dieser Helferin noch nie passiert ist, dass sie jemanden über 15 gefragt hat, was wollen sie, Cola. Okay, wunderbar, haben wir da. Also das war so eine ganz komische Situation, wo ich dann auch so kurz irritiert, was? Wo sie sich auch schon wahrscheinlich gefragt hat, warum kann der das so genau benennen das ist schon irritierend ja weil du jeden tag da bist und nur da beim zahnarzt bist weil du dieses bananen geschmack so geil findest ja aber das ist das ist genauso wie wenn du irgendwie das gebrochenen arm und du kriegst beim arzt verband und er fragt dich ja welches motiv hätten sie denn und du sagst garfield und er sagt okay haben wir da Ja, so, okay. Welcher Garfield soll's denn sein? Ja, welches Motiv hätten sie denn? Und du sagst Garfield und er sagt, okay, haben wir da.
Welcher Garfield soll es denn sein? Der Skateboardfragende, der Essende? Was hätten sie gern? Ich hätte gern den Paraglide fliegenden Garfield. Okay, haben wir da. Gerade frisch reingekommen, gute Wahl. Aber die besten Gelegenheiten sind, wenn man Gags macht, aber sie komplett überhaupt nicht funktionieren, weil sie tatsächlich zu nah an der Realität sind. So dass man das ganz Spezielle sagt, aber es stimmt dann tatsächlich. Ja, dann geht der Gag aber irgendwie, der geht dann nicht auf, weil er halt wahr ist, da hast du recht. Das ist halt ein gutes, ein ganzes Problem. Mir fällt da jetzt Registrier drauf ein. Aber ich finde, manchmal muss man einfach auch all in gehen. Wenn du sowas gefragt wirst, nicht einfach, ja, was haben sie denn da, hier und da, sondern einfach all in gehen und einfach mal sagen, was man gerne hätte. Und haben die es. Vielleicht haben die es denn einfach. Aber das ist immer dasselbe. Da war ich auch bei diesem Burgerladen und dann hieß es, ja, welches Brot hätten Sie denn gerne? Und da musst du doch sagen, ja, was haben Sie denn für Brot hier? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir noch nie Gedanken über Burgerbrot gemacht, keine Ahnung. Aber da einfach mal sagen, welches Brot hätten Sie denn gern Roggen? Okay, bam, einfach in your face. Garfield, okay, Garfield. Ja. Immer wenn ich bei McDonalds bin, freue ich mich immer so sehr, wenn die mir keine Fragen stellen muss. Wenn du einfach sagen kannst, wenn sie fragt, welche Soße darf es denn sein, und du sagst, sie ist sauer, und du weißt, dass sie es haben, und das beschleunigt den Prozess, und du freust dich, dass du die Leute hinter dir lachst, dann so selbstgefällig an, weil du denkst, ja, ich weiss genau, was es hier gibt und ihr seid auch gleich dran. So nach dem Motto.
Oder du nimmst es sogar vorweg.
Ja genau, bevor du dir die Frage stellst.
Also du sagst Chicken McNuggets mit Süssauer. Da gab es ja früher in den 90ern mal die McDonalds-Werbung, wo sozusagen zwei Jugendliche bei McDonalds waren und die Bedienung hat immer mehr Fragen gestellt, so zu mitnehmen mit Mayo oder Ketchup.
Und dann haben die Jugendlichen sich zur Aufgabe gemacht, die Bestellung so zu formulieren, dass keine Frage offen bleibt. Und das war so die Werbung, so wir kümmern uns um all ihre Angelegenheiten. Das war eine richtig geile Werbung, weil das so eins zu eins das ist, was man tatsächlich erlebt bei McDonald's. Das ist nicht so, ja, wir sind die Besten der Welt und wir haben das beste Essen der Welt, sondern sie greifen etwas aus dem Alltag aus, was der Kunde tatsächlich erlebt und woran der Kunde sich tatsächlich erinnert.
Und das ist eine super Werbung.
McDonalds hat auch relativ früh versucht oder relativ früh verstanden, gute Werbung zu machen.
Das ist mir damals schon immer aufgefallen. Das waren immer lustige Werbungen, die haben sich von anderen unterschieden,
die waren irgendwie, die waren aus dem Leben, wie du sagst, auch realistisch und nicht irgendwie so ein,
wir sind die beste Marke dieser Branche, Scheiss, wie bei allen anderen. Das hat mir immer sehr gut gefallen. Und es kommt nichts. Von Florentin Will kommt nichts. Ich habe gerade nachgedacht, ob mir irgendwelche Burger King-Werbungen einfallen, aber ich habe auch schon lange, also ich habe schon lange keine Fernsehwerbung mehr angeschaut, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich auch nicht. Weiss ich es nicht. Naja, anderes Thema. Ich habe noch eine Anekdote, wenn du jetzt nichts hast, aber jetzt hau du erst mal was raus. Ne, ich wollte nur sagen, ich war ja in Berlin, wollte ich dir noch erzählen. Ja, das habe ich schon verstanden, aber was ist denn da passiert? Ja, mein Gott, wir waren zwei Tage da, wir waren im Musical, im Musical da passiert nichts, außer dass Leute da sind, die auf den Sack gehen und die Sekt trinken Und sonst war da jetzt nicht so viel. Wir waren ja auch nur zwei Tage da. Es war ein Geschenk. In welchem Musical warst du denn? Hinterm Horizont. Udo Lindenberg Musical. Es war viel, es wurde gelacht, es wurde getanzt, viel geweint wurde auch, weil es ja hier um dieses, es ging um dieses Ostwest-Kick. Auf der Bühne oder im Parkett? Hauptsächlich von mir wurde viel geweint und viel getanzt. Okay. Auch auf dem Parkett. Es war ja, nee, es ging ja um diese Ost-West-Geschichte und Teilung und war ja direkt ein Potsdamer Platz. Das war in der Tat ganz cool, dass es halt genau da stattfand, wo es halt spielt auch. Das ist halt nicht so schlecht, aber es ist halt halt Musical. Gut, muss man irgendwie auch Liebhaber sein. Ich glaube, ich war noch nie in einem Musical tatsächlich. Noch nie? Ich glaube, ich war einmal mit unserer Geschichtsklasse in der Schule in einem Musical. Das war so ein Geschichtsmusical. Ich weiss nicht mehr genau, aber da ging es irgendwie dann um Nazi. Das klingt furchtbar. Da wurde so eine gewisse Zeitepoche als Musical dargestellt. Und als Kind sitzt du da drin und denkst, ja okay, jetzt pass mal auf, Leute. Ich finde Geschichte extrem langweilig und ich finde Musicals extrem langweilig. Was erwartet ihr euch von dieser Geschichte hier? Minus bei Minus ergibt Plus? Ja, genau. Nein, tut es nicht. Das mag in der Mathematik manchmal richtig sein, aber im Leben nie. Es stimmt nie.
Was haben die denn über Epochen gesungen oder was? Biedermeier ist die beste Zeit.
Und der, das weiss ich noch, weil ich meine, der, vor dem Lehrer ist ja schon eine gewisse Respektsperson und man möchte ja auch vor dem Lehrer eigentlich gut dastehen. Und auch wenn es einem nicht gefällt, man tut ja vor dem Lehrer schon so, als wäre man da jetzt total interessiert und sehr unhöflich dann, wenn der Lehrer, aber bei uns war es dann so, da war dann Pause und wir sind gegangen so, boah, ganz schön lang, bin ich eigentlich ganz froh, dass es vorbei ist. Wie vorbei? Das ist nur die Pause. Und dann uns wirklich alles aus den Gesichtern gefallen so, was? Also da konnte man nichts mehr verbergen, da war nur noch so ein Wie bitte? Wir hatten auch mal so ein Theaterstück, wo wir vor der Schule waren, das war so eine englische Theatergruppe, die ist mal von Schule zu Schule gereist und da musste man da halt hin, das war eine Pflichtveranstaltung, man musste auch noch Geld bezahlen für und irgendwann so, als die Schulklassen dann in dieses pubertierende, sehr pubertierende, hoch pubertierende Zeitalter kam, da fing sie dann an, dass es ganz schnell so nach zehn Minuten das Stück gekippt ist und irgendwann so die Schüler angefangen haben, so eine Eigeninitiative zu ergreifen, irgendwelche, irgendwelche Auftritte von einer bestimmten Rolle zu bejubeln und es wurde so sehr ironisch direkt immer. Aber so sehr, dass mir dann auch schon mal ein bisschen leid tat, weil es dann so sehr ironisch halt aufgenommen wurde von den Leuten und die Lehrer, die völlig verzweifelt durch die Reihen gegangen sind und die Handys aufgesammelt haben und so. Ist auch ein Scheissjob. Ja, das finde ich tatsächlich auch zu viel. Und das gab es bei mir tatsächlich nie in der Schule, dass sowas wirklich ganz komplett sabotiert wurde. Doch, bei uns total. Die Leute sind ausgerastet. Theater ist halt nichts mehr. Aber da hatten wir, wir mussten ja auch ihr musstet ja auch Iphigenia auf Taures lesen? Ja. Das war bei uns so ein Ding, wo wir dann zum Theaterstück gegangen sind und das war wirklich schlimm. Das ist ganz schnell, ganz laut geworden und so und die Leute haben das nicht gefeiert. Gut ist auch jetzt nicht so ein tolles Stück. Ich kann mich noch an einen Moment erinnern, als ich eine Klausur, ich hatte ja Deutsch-LK, Klausur geschrieben habe, wir gehen ja auf Tauris und ich bin wütend geworden, dass da so viele Frauen mitspielen. Weil wenn du diesen Aufsatz schreibst und du beschreibst eine Beziehung zwischen zwei Frauen, musst du ständig immer wieder den Namen sagen, weil du kannst nicht sagen, ja, aber sie steht ihr für, aber sie steht ihr für. Du musst immer den Namen, und ich weiss auch, wie ich wütend war und so kurz auf den Tisch gehauen habe, weil mich das so genervt hat, dass ich immer wieder die ganzen Namen ausschreibe, die Iphigenie und diese andere lange Name und ich so fuck seiten Männer verdammt nochmal. War eine komische Phase. Habt ihr auch die Buddenbrucks gelesen eigentlich? Och Gott, ey. Die sind ja nicht nur alle von einem Geschlecht, sondern die haben auch noch den gleichen Namen teilweise. Da muss Thomas Mann damals, hat vorgelesen, er hat vorgesessen vor seinem Manuskript wahrscheinlich, und da sind einfach keine Namen mehr eingefallen. Er hat die längste Geschichte der Welt gefühlt geschrieben, aber ihm sind die Namen irgendwann ausgegangen. Also an Kreativität scheitert es dem Mann ja offensichtlich nicht, aber er hat einfach keine Namen mehr gehabt. Ja, vor allem stell dir mal vor, du liest das Buch irgendjemandem vor und der andere wieder, ja, welcher Buddenbrucks? Und dann sagte Buddenbrucks und plötzlich kam Buddenbrucks durch die Tür und sagte, habt ihr schon gehört, dass Buddenbrucks tot ist? Und alle nur so, wer jetzt genau war es? Alle nur so, Moment, ganz kurz, bevor wir trauern. Leute, ganz kurz nochmal, wer liegt im Sarg? Können wir das nochmal ganz kurz? Wer lebt handhoch? Ganz kurz durchzählen, dann wissen wir vielleicht, wer ist in der Interviewstadt. Aber ich glaube, das war damals sogar in den Adelsfamilien tatsächlich ein Problem, dass sich die Leute zu ähnlich waren und man dann Storys erzählt hat von irgendwelchen Leuten und am Ende so muss man sagen, ja, coole Story, aber ich habe jetzt echt keine Ahnung, um wen es geht. Das war bestimmt gut. Und du hast mir gestern die Story auch schon erzählt und vorgestern so, sorry, ich dachte, du wärst jemand anders, tut mir leid.
Ich meine, ich will nicht ins Rassistische abdriften, um das mal ganz kurz zu sagen, aber wie ist es denn in asiatischen Ländern, da müssen solche Probleme ja eigentlich vorherrschen. Ich fände auch, hast du damals auch immer Detektiv Conan geguckt? Das ist so eine Kinderserie, die ich total gefeiert habe. Ja, ich habe mich geliebt. Die ich mir auch immer noch gerne angucke bei YouTube, wenn man so nostalgische Momente hat. Ich habe da sogar Manga gelesen. Echt? Ne, das fand ich mir creepy. Solche Leute waren immer ein bisschen creepy, die das gemacht haben. Aber nicht viele, also nicht viele, nur ein paar. Manga-Leser wurden bei uns ausgegrenzt und in den Spind gekettet. Ja, und du meinst, da gab es auch mal Verwirrung oder wie, dass die alleltersten? Ja, nee, da ging es mir jetzt im Nachhinein, wenn ich jetzt noch gucke, geht es mir so, dass ich die Namen mir nicht behalten kann, einfach weil die klingen halt zu anders. Und da klingen auch alle irgendwie ähnlich. Das stimmt, ja. Und das ist mega schwierig als Kind auch schon, dann anscheinend die ganzen Namen nicht zu behalten, und es sind ja teilweise nicht so einfache Kriminalfälle, ne, die du dann wirklich, wo du dann davor sitzt und denkst, wow, es hat ihn getroffen, Moment, das war jetzt, wer hat das jetzt nochmal, aber naja. Ja, aber das geht mir tatsächlich oft so, auch bei so neueren Science-Fiction-Filmen, irgendwie Guardians of the Galaxy oder Hobbit oder so, das ist kein Science-Fiction, aber so wahnsinnig viele Figuren, wo man auch einfach sagt so, oh nein, er war's, okay, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Das ganze Kino schreckt auf und man guckt sich nur so Hilfe so rundum. Wie? Verstehe ich? Nee, aber das haben die ja bei Hobby-Digens lustig gemacht. Also J.R.R. Tolkien hat ja einfach die ganzen Zwerge so mega behindert genannt. Oh Gott, wie furchtbar. Ja, Gimli, Fimli, Schimli. Ja, die haben ja alle ähnliche Namen. Es mag realistisch sein, Tolkien, aber es wäre schon cool, wenn die irgendwie Klaus, Ralf und Peter hießen, damit man da zumindest ... Oder, oder, Zwerg eins, Zwerg zwei und Zwerg drei. Das wäre noch viel einfacher. Wäre halt ein bisschen lame zu lesen. Ich meine, es gibt ja die Legende von Bruce Lee, und zwar, dass Bruce Lee niemals gestorben ist, sondern nur in den Untergrund abgetaucht ist und da als Undercover Cop arbeitet. Ein paar Fragen an diese Legende. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie Polizeicommissioner ist, sucht man sich als Undercover Cop wirklich den berühmtesten Chinesen der Welt aus und setzt den als Abercop so, hey, kann ich mal eurer Gang mitmachen, ich will irgendwie Drogen verkaufen. Ja, aber ganz kurze Frage, bist du nicht fucking Bruce Lee? Nein, nein, ich bin nicht Bruce Lee. Aber auf der anderen Seite, man muss sagen, bei den Chinesen ist es ja eh so, dass sie sich eh, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen Stereotyp und so, aber ich glaube, da ist es nicht so schwer, Undercover Cop zu sein, oder? wenn man dann sagt, hier... Da könntest sogar du Undercover-Cop sein. Du musst aber die Augen zusammenkneifen, dann läufst du da rum und alle würden dich aufnehmen. Ja, jetzt wird's rassistisch. Nee, ich ... Augen zusammenkneifen war zu viel. Du, das war jetzt Satire, nennt man das. Aber zum Beispiel, ich finde es tatsächlich ... Sind wir eigentlich ein Satire-Podcast? Ich glaube nicht. Apropos Satire, zum Thema Tiere. Bei Tieren ist es ja, glaube ich, relativ einfach. So bei Katzen oder so, die haben ja alle eine verschiedene Fellfarbe. Die sehen ja sehr unterschiedlich aus. Da kann man sagen, ah, hier, cool, du bist die rote und du bist schwarze, passt. Aber auf den ersten Blick, wenn die gleiche Art sieht, sieht das schon mal sehr ähnlich aus. Wenn die gleiche Fellfarbe ungefähr gleich ist, dann auf den ersten Blick würdest du dich ja nicht auseinanderhalten können.
Ja, oder so Regenwürmer oder so, da muss man echt sagen, ey, sorry, aber zieht euch mal irgendwie einen Hut auf oder irgendwie so einen Hut oder irgendwie einen Schal.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wer ihr seid. Ich feiere mit euch Weihnachten, aber seid ihr meine Familie, ja oder nein, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber so einen Regenwurm mit so einem Trenchcoat, den würde ich auch erst mal für voll nehmen.
Ja, okay, das ist ein Regenwurm wie alle anderen. Ich liebe ja die Serie Bojack Horseman. Und da gab es tatsächlich eine Folge, wo eine Figur eingeführt wurde, die aus drei Kindern besteht, die aufeinander stehen und einen langen Trenchcoat haben. Und das ist so lustig, weil dieses Bild kennt man ja aus vielen Serien, aber den einfach als komplett normale Figur zu handhaben, der einfach normal mit den anderen agiert, ist schon echt lustig. Also kann ich jedem nur ans Herz legen, BoJack Horseman. Ich hätte jetzt noch eine andere Knaller-Anekdote, wenn du jetzt nicht sagst Veto, wenn du noch ein paar rassistische Hass-Tiraden von Dunn lassen möchtest. Du, ich wollte nur weiterführen, was du angefangen hast. Ich bin nur auf den Zugriffpunkt, den du gefahren bist. Mein Computer ist sehr dreckig. Also ich mache an meinem Rechner sehr viel, ich esse daran und spucke darauf und alles hier und da und verschiedene Körperflüssigkeiten fliessen in seiner Nähe und das führt dazu, dass der Bildschirm relativ dreckig ist. Und jetzt ist es so, dass es dann halt so manchmal so verschiedene Flecken auf dem Bildschirm gibt, die man dann entfernt. Und jetzt fallen einem die aber nicht immer direkt auf, weil man schaut ja nicht immer an die ähnlichen Stellen auf seinem Bildschirm. Und jetzt ist es oft so, dass wenn man sich ein Video anschaut von Menschen, dann schaut man ja meistens direkt auf die Gesichter. Und dann fällt einem auf, dass auf dem Bildschirm, wo gerade das Gesicht zu sehen ist, ein Fleck ist. Und dann wische ich den Fleck so ab. Das ist nämlich genau das gleiche auch. Ja, aber das Problem ist manchmal... Es sieht aus, als würde man die streicheln, sieht das nämlich aus. Ja, genau, genau, das war die ... Das ist so mega ... Und ich hab übrigens ... Au, scheiße, das ist gerade ... Das hab ich genau ... Und dann hab ich nämlich, ich hab an meinem PC was geschnitten. Und zwar, wir haben auch zusammen fürs Neo-Magazin, haben wir ja was gedreht, ne? Weißt du vielleicht. Will ich jetzt nicht zu viel verraten, wird alles noch veröffentlicht und so. Und das habe ich geschnitten und dann habe ich das irgendwem gezeigt und habe dann denen halt die Reaktionen abwarten wollen, ob es lustig ist und so. Und dann habe ich, dann habe ich, dann kam plötzlich so ein Still von dir, weil ich habe es irgendwie angehalten, die Szene, und dann war es so halt zu sehen und da war es so genau ein Flecken und ein Fussel, so eine kleine schwarze Fussel war genau auf deiner Nase oder so.. Dann habe ich die halt weggemacht, weil man das ja gerade sieht, weil der Rest ist ja dunkel meistens und Hautfarbe ist halt hell. Dann machst du es weg und dann neben mir sitzt dann ein Kollege, den du auch gern, der ist dann wieder, äh, warum hast du denn gerade den Flur, hat nie gestreichelt. Und das war mir dann richtig, richtig unangenehm, aber es ist halt so. Ja, aber das passiert mir wirklich auch oft und man macht das so ganz instinktiv, so dass man gar nicht merkt, wenn andere Leute dabei sind. Und auch gerade irgendwie dann bei Kindern oder so ist es so creepy, wenn man dann so und auch so ein bisschen hin und her rubbelt, so den Fleck nicht gleich abkriegt. Und der Betrachter sich einfach nur denken muss, sag mal, was ist denn gerade hier los? Was beobachte ich hier gerade? So unangenehm. Es ist mir schon unangenehm, wenn ich alleine bin.
Ja, man denkt dann immer dran und man denkt sich dann, manchmal denke ich mir echt bewusst,
okay, ich warte, bis der nächste Schnitt kommt und mache dann den Fleck weg,
weil ich kann jetzt einfach nicht dieser Frau ins Gesicht fassen, weil das so strange aussieht.
Das ist echt gut, das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Aber ich hätte das jetzt, das stimmt, das ist mir aber gar nicht so bewusst geworden. Das unterscheidet uns, weil du machst dir Dinge bewusst. Das ist, glaube ich, der Trick. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Pages offen habe, ist ja auch viel weiss. Da ist der ganze Bildschirm noch nicht weiss, aber da habe ich nicht den Drang, irgendwie so Flecken wegzumachen. Aber wenn ich ein Gesicht sehe, hat man es irgendwie. Ja, bei Texteverarbeitung hast du keinen konkreten Fokus, auf den du konzentrierst. Du bist eher generell konzentriert, aber wenn man ein Video anschaut, schaut man halt direkt an Gesichter und das ist einfach so strange. Das ist echt creepy. Vor allem das kann man auch niemandem erklären. Man kann doch nicht sagen, ja, da war gerade ein Fleck, weil das klingt einfach wie die schlechteste Entschuldigung aller Zeiten. Aber es ist wirklich so, euer Ehren, das war jetzt, ich wollte nicht dem Kind, aber ich meine, zum Glück ist es ja das Gesicht, ich kann mir andere Körperteile vorstellen, die noch unangenehmer wären, wo man seinen Fokus drauf richtet. Aber da sieht man den Fleck dann nicht, da sieht man meistens den Fleck dann nicht. Naja, wenn du sagst Hautfarbe sieht man gut. Gut, anderes Thema.
Oh ja, ja, ja.
Ui, du.
Ui, ja, ja, ja.
Tut mir leid, das war zu viel, das war zu viel. Ne, was ich mir heute, also ich war heute in Berlin, ich werde auch nicht müde, das zu erzählen. Und wie gesagt, den ersten Tag waren wir da und dann haben wir diese Sightseeing-Busse gesehen, die dich ja auch als Berliner, dich müssen die ja unfassbar abfacken. Die sind ja überall, überall sind Busse, die haben sogar eine eigene Spur. Busse haben in Berlin so eine eigene Busspur. Und da fahren auch dann so richtige Raudis, die fahren dann da auch drauf und fahren dann rechts, links vorbei an den Leuten. Und am ersten Tag haben die mich ultra abgefuckt, am zweiten Tag bin ich dann mit so einem Ding gefahren. Und das war ganz schön, ganz schön seltsam, diese Busse, weil du hast ja immer, du hast ja dann im Ohr, hörst du dann ja, wo wir gerade sind und sehen sie jetzt, zu der rechten Seite haben sie den Gendarmenplatz, zu der linken Seite haben sie den Dom und so. Aber meistens ist es vielleicht aufgefallen, kommen diese Dinger, diese Ansagen kommen immer so ein bisschen zu spät, dass du nie genau weißt, welches Gebäude meinen die jetzt und du denkst dann immer, so wildtrennende Geschichten denkst du dir du dir aus zu den Gebäuden, die du gerade siehst, die offensichtlich nicht gemeint sein können. Da war zum Beispiel, da war irgendwie so ein Denkmal und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, das ist so ein Denkmal, das wurde für die Bücherverbrennung errichtet und da sieht man zum Beispiel Kant und Hegel und Schiller und so weiter und das ist einfach so ein Pferd. Und in meinem Dummgehen habe ich mir dann so gedacht, wo auf dem Pferd ist jetzt genau Kant? Wo ist da und wo ist genau Hegel eigentlich? Ich habe es wirklich so zusammengereimt und dachte mir, wow, dieses Pferd, da wo das Pferd stand, da war offensichtlich die Bücherverrennung damals. Und dann fahren wir so ein bisschen weiter, auf einmal steht da Kant und Hegel, alle stehen dann da und dann dachte ich mir auch so, du bist so dämlich. Da habe ich mir gerade noch dieses Pferd so schön geredet, das war eigentlich ganz schön behindert, aber eigentlich ganz schön. Berlin ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig schön. Aber solche Städtefahrten sind tatsächlich immer ein großes Problem, auch weil ich mir nie darüber im Klaren bin, ob das Ganze jetzt links oder rechts stattfindet. Und vor allem, man orientiert sich ja dann auch so ein bisschen am Rest der Gruppe, weil man will ja nicht in die falsche Richtung schauen und man will aber auch nicht desinteressiert wirken, weil man muss ja, man will sich ja am kulturellen Treiben der Stadt beteiligen. Und wenn dann alle nach links gucken und man selber auch nach links guckt und denkt, naja, aber eigentlich der Reichstag ist eigentlich schon rechts irgendwie und dann muss man aber trotzdem nach links gucken, weil man will nicht als einziger, also das ist immer so ein soziales Hin und Her, was wirklich kompliziert ist. Vor allem, was sehr schlimm ist, wenn man solche Touren macht für Städte, die man gut kennt, wo man auch gewohnt hat, wie München zum Beispiel, haben wir mal aus Spars so eine Städtetour gemacht. Aber das Bild, was Ausländern von seiner eigenen Stadt, also seiner gut bekannten Stadtmacht, ist echt teilweise echt creepy. Und was sie dann erzählen, irgendwie da und da, gäbe es die ganz besonderen Spezialitäten und Schmankerl und man war da einfach schon und weiss, dass es irgendwie Glühwein aus dem Tetra Pak ist und dass es überhaupt nichts Besonderes ist. Und dann wird immer so ganz furchtbare Musik eingespielt, so hier ist echte Blasmusik und dann ist das irgendwie so halb Elektropop, halb Blasmusik, so ganz schrecklich. Und man sitzt, es ist echt wirklich furchtbar. Aber es ist mal schön zu sehen, welches Bild andere Leute von der Stadt haben, das man als Einwohner gar nicht hat. Und eigentlich ist das ein schöneres Bild, weil da ist viel mehr Magie und so, ja, und es gibt da ganz besondere Traditionen und so und du nimmst es gar nicht als solches wahr.
Aber ich finde, ich habe Berlin als eine sehr, sehr, sehr schöne Stadt wahrgenommen, wo sehr viele Leute sehr nett sind eigentlich, weil es wirkt irgendwie so, das sind ja alles so, also gerade diese Busse, die man da macht, da kommt man halt nur an so krass geschichtsträchtigen Orten vorbei und irgendwie wirken die Leute auch dann da in der Stadt nicht so, als würden die da wirklich wohnen und als würden die das gehören, sondern als würden die mehr so sich das von der Geschichte quasi leihen. Weißt du, wie ich meine? Dieses, das dachte ich mir heute. Als ich Kant gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, komm, du musst, Stefan, du brauchst jetzt auch irgendwas, du brauchst irgendwas, was zu sagen, wo alle sagen, das ist ein Tietze-Zitat. Brauchst irgendeinen reichstreichen Gedanken, verdammt nochmal. Und kam mir die Idee, die Berliner haben sich die Stadt von der Geschichte geliehen. Das wirkt ja wirklich so. Wow. Kannst du das bitte twittern? Nee, das möchte ich nicht. Jetzt möchte ich nicht. Mit Hashtag Berlin. Doch, ich, nein, aber ich finde, das ist einer der schönsten Gedanken, die du je hattest. Und ich will, dass du den raushaust. Heute tue ich gar nicht mehr, ich habe so Scheisse gebaut heute, ich habe so eine richtige Scheisse gebaut. Es war, also heute, ich habe, in der Unigruppe, bist du auch bestimmt, ach nee, du bist ja nicht mehr am Studieren. Aber ich bin am Studieren und dann ist man halt in so verschiedenen Facebook-Gruppen und WhatsApp-Gruppen und dann ist mir da einer aufgefallen, der schreibt schon seit ein paar Tagen, macht er so, so richtige, so ausländerfeindliche Memes, postet der. Weißt du? Da ist dann so ein Boot, wo Flüchtlinge drauf sind und ich zitiere, da steht drunter, schade, wo ist der weisse Hai, wenn man ihn braucht und man sieht halt ein Boot, wo Flüchtlinge drauf sind, so ein Schlauchboot und das ist wirklich, das ist echt scheisse und da weiss man auch nicht, wie man reagieren soll, oder? Wie willst du da reagieren? Was hättest du gemacht an meiner Stelle? Hättest du darauf reagiert, oder bist, ist ein Florentin Will, dann so besonnen, lehnt sich zurück und denkt, macht mal. Naja, also wenn ich die Person kenne und weiss, dass es ein Gag ist, dann würde ich da schreiben, lol, und dann hat sich die Sache erledigt. Aber wenn ich weiss, der meint das ernst, dann würde ich sagen, ja, fertig. Würdest du was sagen? Weil das ist nämlich die Frage, vor der ich heute stand. Ja, ich habe tatsächlich auch heute relativ lange mit einem Verschwörungstheoretiker diskutiert, was immer sehr, sehr sinnvoll ist, immer mit den Leuten diskutieren, denn auf Argumente und Logik stehen die, das ist ihr Brot und Butter, das ist genau ihr Ding. Und es ist, es führt zu nichts, aber ich finde, man muss da auch die Stimme erheben und einfach zumindest ohne ihn zu überzeugen klar machen, man findet das nicht gut, weil oft wird da einfach das Schweigen der Mehrheit als Bestätigung angesehen und das darf eigentlich nicht. Das dachte ich nämlich auch, die Stimme erheben, aber ich dachte mir auch, dass eine Diskussion nichts bringt, weil man offensichtlich so verschiedene Meinungen hat, dass man wahrscheinlich nicht zusammenkommt. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Dann habe ich... Ja, nee, überhaupt nicht. Man muss ja nicht zusammenkommen, man muss einfach nur sagen, hier, dieser Post beweist, dass du ein ausländerfeindliches Arschloch bist. So, reicht ja schon. Einfach es mal einzuordnen und einfach mal klar zu sagen, hier, was hast du eigentlich gerade gesagt? Das reicht ja oft schon, den Leuten einfach nur zu vermitteln, was sie da eigentlich gerade gesagt haben, ohne dagegen zu halten. Ja, ich habe mich dann im Tweet losgelassen, was ein bisschen dumm war. Ich habe dann so impulsiv geschrieben, ja, irgendeiner aus der Unigruppe postet ausländerfeindliche Memes, Pegida, mach mal was Dummes. So, dann habe ich eine schlagfertige Antwort. So nach dem Motto habe ich was geschrieben, war jetzt auch nicht superlustig, war eher so eine impulsive Entscheidung, das zu machen und dachte mir dann aber im selben Moment, nee, komm, das löschen wir mal lieber besser. Und dann habe ich sofort wieder gelöscht, weil ich dachte, nee, komm, das ist auch irgendwie scheiße. Und dann war ich in der Unigruppe wieder und der einzige, der mich von diesen Leuten gefolgt hat bei Twitter, hat das dann ein Screenshot gemacht natürlich und hat es in die Gruppe gepostet. Und dann war die Kack am Dampfen. Sehr schön. Das war so typisch, dass mir das passiert. Ja, aber ist doch gar nicht schlecht, weil es ist halt deine Meinung. Ich stehe auch weiterhin dahinter. Nö, der hat es nicht verstanden. Ich glaube, die Reaktion war, was ist Pegida? Fertig, Case closed, würde ich sagen. Soll ich das wirklich tun? Nein, ganz kurz, warte mal, ganz kurz. Wir haben ja in der letzten Folge gross angeteasert, mein Abi-Stufen-Treffen.
Ach ja! Ja! Das war gut? Das wollte ich noch fragen. Das ist cool, das sind so Fragen, die habe ich mir nicht aufgeschrieben. Wie muss ich Florentin Wille in seiner Kinderfrau vorstellen, wie war, schreibe ich jetzt im Nachhinein noch auf, wie war eigentlich sein Abi bei? Wie muss man sich Florentin bei seinem Abistreffen vorstellen?
Ja, es ist viel passiert, sage ich mal, aber tatsächlich nichts. Also es ist tatsächlich sehr überraschend, wie schlecht man doch mit manchen Leuten connectet. Also man denkt sich mit Leuten, mit denen man auch früher relativ, also so ein moderates bis mässiges Verhältnis hatte, wie da tatsächlich auch überhaupt nichts bei rumkommen kann. Und vor allem, man denkt sich ja immer, man ist ein gesprächiger Typ, man ist ein bisschen gesellig, man hat einen Podcast, man labert den ganzen Tag, das ist kein Problem. Aber tatsächlich, man sagt, ja, was machst du so? Ja, ich studiere Germanistik. Und du? Ja, ich bin jetzt Berlin, mache ich Sachen. Okay. und mehr vorbei. Und mehr kommt nicht. Es ist sofort vorbei. Vor allem, du kannst der gesprächsische Typ der Welt sein, da kommst du einfach nicht raus. Was will man denn da sagen? Ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man mit Leuten, mit denen man viel Zeit verbringt und so, dass man da automatisch so ein Gesprächsverhältnis aufbaut. Du fängst halt an, Sachen zu erzählen, automatisch, andere Sachen anzuerzählen, aber sobald halt keine Vertrauensbasis da ist, auch keine Zeit mehr irgendwie verbindet irgendwie, oder keine Interessen mehr verbinden, möglicherweise habt ihr ja ganz andere Leben gelebt in der Zeit, da kommt auch noch nicht viel. Da sind ja auch komplett verschiedene Wellen. Aber man denkt, man hätte sich so wahnsinnig viel zu erzählen, vor allem auch, ja, erinnerst du dich noch damals, aber du hast mit den Leuten einfach damals noch nichts zu tun gehabt und du hast auch einfach alles vergessen, was passiert ist. Ich hatte irgendwie keine Ah, weisst du noch damals, als Feueralarm war und wir beiden zusammen im Schnee und keine Ahnung, was auch immer, habe ich alles vergessen, ich hatte einfach keine Ahnung mehr. Ich habe auch einen grossen Teil der Namen tatsächlich vergessen. Ich dachte, ich war gut vorbereitet. Aber dann war das immer so, ah, hey, Franken, also, ja, irgendwie. Also, ich habe das tatsächlich, glaube ich, relativ gut als Ironie verkaufen können, so, haha, mir fällt nicht ein, wie du heisst, aber ich habe tatsächlich den Namen vergessen. Also, es können ja mal ein paar Leute schreiben, die jetzt gerade zuhören und die dabei waren, also um den Hörerkreis noch weiter einzugreifen. Also keiner. Aber hast du denn erzählt, denn erzählt, dass du vom Fernsehen bist oder haben sich die Leute erkannt? Ja, also das war dann schon so. Was aber tatsächlich auch eine unangenehme Situation ist, so ja, haha, du bist jetzt der grosse Fernsehstar. Aber was will man denn darauf sagen als ja oder nein oder ach, ich habe keine Ahnung. Also natürlich objektiv nein im Verhältnis zu allem, was ihr jemals erreichen werdet, natürlich schon, aber weißt du, man kann es ja nicht sagen, ja, aber verstehst du nicht, es ist halt was anderes, ob man das aus einer Situation betrachtet, das ist genauso wie wenn du irgendwie einen Artikel in der SZ veröffentlicht hättest, ein Artikel vor drei Jahren und dann sagt man, ja, du bist der große Journalist, da kannst du ja auch nicht sagen, ja, stimmt, du kannst aber auch nicht sagen, nein,
das stimmt nicht, weil aus deren Perspektive,
die da null haben oder für die null die Regel ist, geht es natürlich
auch nicht viel. Und das ist natürlich auch blöd, weil
wie kann man darüber reden, ohne das komplett
arrogante Arschloch zu sein?
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Es war tatsächlich alles in allem relativ
ernüchternd,
sag ich mal, aber ich glaube, man muss da auch ein bisschen reinkommen, irgendwie. Ich sage mal, den meisten Spaß hatte ich mit Leuten, die nicht auf meiner Stufe waren, die einfach so dabei waren, habe ich mir dann nichts unterhalten. Die einfach fremd waren. Aber es ist tatsächlich echt ein großer Unterschied, wie man in Gespräch reinkommt. Wenn man gut reinkommt, kann man sich auch wahnsinnig lange mit jemandem unterhalten, aber wenn man einfach nicht reinkommt, und es ist tatsächlich extrem unangenehm, aber man konnte wahnsinnig gut Soziales vermeiden lernen. Weil stell dir mal vor, du stehst dann mit jemandem da und sagst, ja was machst du so, ich studiere A, der andere sagt, ich studiere B, Punkt. und dann vergehen fünf Sekunden und irgendwas muss passieren. Und der andere irgendwie hat anscheinend nicht diese soziale Fähigkeit,
einfach das zu bemerken, dass es jetzt total awkward ist und guckt dich einfach nur an. Wenn du die Pause ausklingen lässt, dann ist verloren, hast du wirklich gestorben einfach. Ja, vor allem, du darfst die Pause nicht als Pause bestehen lassen. Dem anderen darf die Pause eigentlich nicht ausfallen. Du musst eigentlich schon eine Sekunde, bevor die Pause unangenehm wird, musst du schon eingreifen und sagen, ah, hey, Karl, an einem Ende des Raumes, ey, ich muss kurz mal zu Karl und kurz begrüßen, ich komme gleich wieder und gehst, kommst natürlich nie wieder zurück, aber das musst du schon vorgreifen. Und deswegen war es bei mir oft so, dass ich direkt begrüsst habe, hi, ja, wie geht's, gut, gut und sofort gesagt habe, ah, hey, ich muss doch irgendwie Lisa begrüßen und bin sofort rübergegangen. Und bei Lisa dasselbe. Und so habe ich mich durch den ganzen Raum gepingpongt und alle dachten sich wahrscheinlich, was für ein Arsch. Bis du alle durchhaltest, bis du alle Namen erfunden hast, die schon unrealistisch wirken. Zwerg Eins oder Thomas Bodenbrück? Ne, warte mal, ich wollte noch was erzählen. Und zwar bei uns ist immer die After X-mas party, die ist bei uns in der Stadthalle in Cham. Da ist immer, das ist irgendwie so eine Tradition, warum auch immer, warum man auch immer Weihnachten feiern muss oder so. Das habe ich mir nie erschlossen, aber irgendwie ist es so, dass so eine Riesen-Partysause am ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag direkt abends in Kamen steigt, in der Stadthalle. Und da habe ich irgendwie irgendwann, ich hätte auch so gar keinen Bock und dann dachte ich mir, ja komm, aber alle Leute sind da und du musst halt irgendwie auch hingehen. Da habe ich irgendwann mir so eine Haltung angeeignet, ich habe einfach jedem, weil wenn du auf Tanzflächen bist, du wirst immer angerempelt, du bist immer der Mittelpunkt, weil alle da gerade lang gehen wollen, wo du stehst. Das geht mir halt immer so, allen anderen glaube ich auch, weil alle werden immer angerempelt und dann habe ich mir relativ früh angewöhnt, allen zu sagen, immer frühe Weihnachten zu wünschen, weil er einfach so behindert ist. Einfach jedem, der mich angerehmt hat, hat, echt nett gegrüsst und frohe Weihnachten gewünscht und so. Das war richtig, richtig schön. Und alle haben auch dann zurück frohe Weihnachten gewünscht und es war richtig so eine Liebe, ich habe so eine Liebe ausgestrahlt. Wenn du allen frohe Weihnachten wünschst, du hast mit allen direkt was zu erzählen, alle fanden an, von seinen Feiertagen zu erzählen, von ihrem Festessen, die sie gegessen haben, von weiss nicht, wie es ihnen gerade geht. Du schaltest einfach so eine Wärme aus, wenn du allen frohe Weihnachten wünschst. Das war sehr lustig und das war eine gute Erfahrung. Aber ich sage mal, so ein Gesprächsanlass ist natürlich immer gut, weil man ein Gespräch anfangen kann, kann aber auch das Gespräch relativ schnell ersticken, indem man sagt, ja und ja, wie hast du gefeiert, ja mit der Familie war schön und du ja, mit der Familie war schön, Punkt. Genau. Und dann ist es die erste kritische Phase. Es wäre besser, wenn Gespräche eher natürlich entstehen und man keinen Anlass hat und man einfach schon direkt am Anfang schon die Power da reinsetzen muss, ein Gespräch anzufangen, anstatt ein Gespräch einfach anfangen zu können, dann aber relativ schnell in der Sackgasse zu sein, ohne dass es dann weitergeht. Das stimmt. Weil dann wird es unangenehm. Ich war bei fast allen an diesem unangenehmen Punkt, aber da bin ich einfach weitergegangen. Das ist einfach der Punkt, wo du dann früh genug entscheiden musst, zu gehen. Das hast du auch gemacht. Es ist teilweise immer schwierig, wenn man bei Leuten eine gewisse Reflexionsgabe voraussetzt, die sie nicht haben. Weil meine Strategie ist dann einfach oft, wenn ich in einer unangenehmen Situation bin, ich rede über diese unangenehme Situation und frage, ist euch das gerade auch total unangenehm oder was für eine strange Situation, weil das ist eigentlich das interessanteste Gesprächsthema, ist die Absurdität der Situation. Man hat sich vier Jahre nicht getroffen und denkt, jetzt ist das grosse Hallo, aber man schafft es irgendwie nicht zu connecten und irgendwie haben sich alle verändert und guckt dir mal die an irgendwie, war die in unserem Jahrgang oder ist die einfach nur extrem hässlich geworden, man weiß es nicht und das sind eigentlich die interessanten Themen, aber die meisten Leute haben einfach diese Reflexionsgabe nicht und du sagst dann, ist das nicht auch total strange, ja was meinst du denn, ist doch schön die wieder zu treffen, ja schon, aber da kommst du nicht weiter, du kommst einfach durch diese Mauer nicht durch. Nee, genau. Das sind also Leute, die mittlerweile auf einer ganz anderen Wellenlänge schwimmen. Und Humor ist einfach tödlich. Humor ist, ich merke das immer wieder, Humor ist tödlich. Humor funktioniert nicht im echten Leben. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Humor funktioniert nicht im normalen Leben und eigentlich gar nicht. Auch schon gar nicht über Telefon, glaube ich. Humor funktioniert entweder nur zwischen, sag ich mal, passiv und aktiv, also jemand steht auf der Bühne und die anderen hören nur zu, oder es funktioniert wirklich, wenn zwei, sag ich mal, sehr humoristische Leute sich zufällig treffen. Mit einer normalen Person kann man eigentlich relativ selten wirklich lustig sprechen, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Man kommt da einfach nicht an. Also bei uns wäre das quasi eher das Aktiv-Passiv-Verhältnis.
Flur und den Willer erzählen eine Geschichte und ich dazu.
Aber es ist auch gut. Du lachst ab und zu gezwungen und höflich.
Ja. Hahaha.
Ah, sehr schön.
Das ist mein Klingelton mittlerweile übrigens für SMS, ist dein herzliches Lachen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Du hast doch neulich mal geschrieben, du hasst die Radio-Fritzen.
Meintest du damit Radio-Fritzen.
Meintest du damit Radio-
Darf ich das sagen eigentlich?
Ja, na ja.
Also es kommt darauf an, ob wir noch ins Radio wollen oder nicht.
Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Radio-Fritzen ...
Aber dieser eine Typ von den Radio-Fritzen ist doch auch der Chefredakteur von Halligalli, oder?
Ja!
Und das habe ich nämlich ... Ich war ja in Berlin, weiß ich nicht, also ob ich es schon mal erzählt habe. Echt? Wann warst du in Berlin? Ja, jetzt die letzten Tage. Und da habe ich Radio Fritz gehört und da war genau nämlich der Redaktionsleiter von der Sendung, die du meinst, da auch on air. Und das war wirklich nicht lustig. Es war sogar so schlimm irgendwann, dass man sich überlegt hat, einfach umzuschalten vielleicht. Ja, aber das ist auch so eine, also ich finde, Radiomoderatoren sind oft Leute, denen nie gesagt wurde, dass sie nicht lustig sind. Und das ist ganz teuflisch. Vielleicht weil die Strukturen da zu einfach sind. Da wird man einfach durchgewunken. Mit Abitur, komm, vor's Mikro, hier, nimm einfach. Und du bist live dran in fünf, vier, drei. So ist das, glaube ich. Ja, beim Radio ist es tatsächlich auch so anders als auf einer Bühne oder so. Du kriegst ja auch keine Rückmeldung. Und du kriegst ja auch relativ selten über Kommentare. Ja, doch mittlerweile glaube ich schon. Über E-Mails bekommen. Meinst du denn, wird gesagt, du bist nicht lustig? Twitter und E-Mail und so? Also ich habe bei der Zeit schon damals die krasse Erfahrung gemacht, dass Leute wegen allem Scheiss schreiben. Also auch gerade wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, äh, glaube ich moderiert auch, sich gerade in die Öffentlichkeit begibt, ist, glaube ich, die Resonanz enorm. Dort glaube ich schon. Die kriegen gesagt, die sind nicht lustig, aber die nehmen das vielleicht ironisch wahr oder so. Weiss ich nicht. Aber es war wirklich schlimm. Also verstehe ich schon. Da wollen wir nicht unbedingt hin.
Ja, ich habe gerade bei Facebook die Radio-Fritzen eingeben und Facebook in seiner allwissenden Weisheit führt mich auf die persönliche Page von Diego Andres Amoroccio Suarez. Einfach direkt autocomplete. Nein, danke. Ich habe tatsächlich letztens, ist es eigentlich creepy, wenn man Leuten, mit denen man nicht befreundet ist, auf Facebook was schreibt? Bei mir landet das dann immer ein sonstiges Ordner. Das ist so ein ganz versteckter Ordner, den man nicht findet. Aber da muss man manchmal auch einfach reinschauen. Aber das ist echt so eine tolle Überraschungsbox, weil da sieht man dann so, ah, okay, irgendwelche Events haben sich gemeldet, so, hey, willst du nicht Blut spenden oder irgendein Kram? Ganz seltsame Anfragen, die dann kommen. Aber ich habe letztens einen slowenischen Film gesehen, den ich sehr gut fand und habe dann die ganzen Schauspieler gestalkt, die alle keine professionellen Schauspieler waren, weil sie Jugendliche waren. Einen slowenischen Film? Ja, und habe dann auch einige Schauspieler gefunden und habe dann die Schauspieler auch tatsächlich auf Facebook gefunden, in ihrem privaten Profil und habe dann einer Schauspielerin geschrieben, hey, ich fand dich sehr gut in dem Film und dachte mir aber, das ist auch sau creepy irgendwie.
Ich habe gleichzeitig noch einen Fleck auf ihrem Gesicht weggemacht und in dem Moment habe ich mich sehr komisch gefühlt und dachte mir, aber andererseits weisst du gerade, wenn du so ein junger Schauspieler bist, ist es doch total cool, aus einem anderen Land eine Message zu bekommen, so hey, coole Arbeit fand ich total cool in dem Film.
Ja, es ist glaube ich eine gute Geste, aber ist glaube ich sozial nicht akzeptiert. Aber das ist tatsächlich Buchmaterial, glaube ich. Also was man in diesem Other, bei mir heisst es Other, alles findet, was da für Sachen kommen. Das stimmt. Also das ist so der Abschaum von Facebook eigentlich, so der, der ausserhalb der Stadtmauer strandet, wo man dann über die Mauer gucken muss und ach, was wollt ihr eigentlich? Aber man muss aktiv erst dahin gucken. Ja, das ist ganz komisch. Ich habe ja mal an so einer Fernsehsendung teilgenommen, die ich jetzt nicht irgendwie näher darauf eingehen will. Aber da habe ich da jetzt relativ spät danach, so ein paar Monate danach, gemerkt, dass ich unfassbar viele Nachrichten bekommen habe. Also für die Verhältnisse. Das kam ja irgendwie nichts danach, außer halt irgendwie so tausend Nachrichten, die in diesem sonstiges Ordner waren und die sind alle gruselig.
Jede einzelne Nachricht ist richtig gruselig.
Und das sind so ganz komische Leute, so ganz verkommene Gesichter, die einen angucken.
Ja, vor allem, es lässt einen auch mal wieder merken, dass es auf Facebook auch einfach Abgründe gibt und einfach ganze Personenkreise und Netzwerke, mit denen man einfach nichts zu tun hat,
die einfach ganz strange Sachen liken und einen ganz komischen Umgangston haben, auch sprachlich,
wenn man sich dann mal die Profile anschaut. Aber war das für dich auch ein Faktor, Facebook weniger zu benutzen? Ja, ich habe vor allem jetzt Twitter für mich entdeckt. Twitter ist halt so ein Ding, wo man auch nicht denkt, dass man sofort verstanden hat. Man will jetzt irgendwie, dass ein System ist, so eine eigene Welt, in die man reinkommen will, aber irgendwie dann auch wieder nicht. Und dann merkt man aber auch, dass da auch komische Leute sind, weil du triffst überall komische Leute. Und bei Twitter ist es nämlich genauso. Da ist halt kein sonstiges Ordner, sondern es ist halt irgendwie ein Hashtag, unter dem so creepy Leute schreiben. Du, ich weiss nicht mehr, ob wir über Twitter reden sollten. Ich finde, jetzt ist es Zeit für deine Joyce-Geschichte. Ich weiss, also warum ich die Joyce-Geschichte ganz ans Ende setzen möchte, ist, ich möchte nicht, dass Joyce sie hört. Weil... Da kann ich dich beschwichtigen. Es geht um Joyce-Erik, ein YouTube-Star, eine ehemalige Schauspielerin oder Amateur-Schauspielerin oder was auch immer, die auf YouTube grossen Erfolg hat und die beim Neo-Magazin zu Gast war. So, und da habe ich sie getroffen. So. Und … Und wie war das? Ähm, ich sag mal so, ich habe jetzt gerade, was weibliche Menschen angeht, nicht die allergrössten Erfolgsgeschichten zu verzeichnen. Deswegen ist sowas für mich immer sehr interessant, weil ich da mit einem gewissen Wagemut rangehen muss und auch einer gewissen Risikofreudigkeit. Und, sag ich mal, Joyce Ilk als Person ist ja, sag ich mal, sehr toll. So, und jetzt vor allem das Ganze wird auch noch unterstrichen, ich weiss nicht, ob du sie auf YouTube verfolgst, aber sie hat so ein Video hochgeladen, wo sie sich so bei so einer Aktion Nackt gegen Pelz beteiligt hat, wo dann auch so wirklich so ein ganz furchtbares Video von der Pelzproduktion, also was wirklich grauenvoll ist, dieses Video, kennstst ja diese Videos, wo dann Tiere unglaublich furchtbar gefoltert werden und bla bla und die geht es wahnsinnig schlecht und so.
Und das hat sie gepostet und das hat alles nochmal viel schlimmer gemacht, weil ich habe, sag ich mal,
also und vor allem das führt ja irgendwie auch alles zusammen, diese Anekdote,
weil auch immer dieses Humor ist eigentlich tödlich, ganz gut verdeutlicht, weil ich sag mal, ich bin natürlich ein toller Typ,
Vielen Dank. Weil auch immer dieses Humor ist eigentlich tödlich, ganz gut verdeutlicht.
Weil, ich sag mal, ich bin natürlich ein toller Typ, aber ich habe oft das Gefühl, dass ich aus dem Blick einer Frau jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu bieten habe, um das jetzt mal so auszudrücken. Deswegen versuche ich diesem Defizit immer zuvor zu kommen mit einer guten Prise Humor. Und da wird es natürlich vor allem dann schwierig, wenn man die betreffende Person nicht gut kennt und nicht weiss, wie sie auf Humor reagiert. Jetzt war es folgende Situation. Joyce Ilk, die wunderschöne bezaubernde Joyce Ilk, war gerade in der Maske und wurde geschminkt und ich wollte an sie herantreten, und dachte mir, ich überlege mir einen kleinen Gag, um gut ins Gespräch zu kommen, um nicht dieses Abi-Problem zu haben, sage ich einem Mitautoren und Mitkollegen von uns, sage ich, ich gehe jetzt rein und dann kommst du kurz zur Tür rein und sagst du ja, Florentin und bringst du diesen klassischen Gag im Sinne von, ja, die Besitzerin des Tierheims wäre jetzt da, die möchte kurz mit dir über den Hund reden, den du von der Strasse gerettet hast. Sowas. Und dann lachen alle und ha ha ha, ein lustiger Gag von wegen. Weil für mich war auch dieses Florentin möchte Joyce beeindrucken, war für mich so allgegenwärtig, weil wir in den Reaktionssitzungen ständig davon gesprochen haben, dass ich so das Gefühl hatte, das wäre jedem bewusst und auch Joyce selbst wäre total bewusst, dass so eine Möchtegern-Romanze besteht und so, aha, er ist in Joyce verliebt und so, dass es alle total auf dem Schirm hätten und deswegen man auch diesen Gag sofort als solchen verstehen würde, so aha, er möchte ein gutes Bild vor Joyce erwecken und hat deswegen so eine Geschichte erfunden, er würde sich um herrenlose Hunde kümmern. Nun ja, ich gehe also in diese Maske rein, Joyce sitzt da, ah hallo hier, du aha, hier, man gibt sich die Hand, hier und da, die Maske kenne ich auch sehr gut, aha, schön euch wiederzusehen, bla bla bla, man redet ein bisschen, dann kommt der Autor rein, irgendwie ich dreh mich zu ihm, er sagt, ja, die Dame wär jetzt da wegen dem Hund, den du von der Strasse gerettet hast. Ich so, ah ja, okay, ich komme kurz raus, schau in die Runde, erwarte schallendes Gelächter, strahlende Gesichter, Bäuche, die gehalten werden, vor Lachen, der eine krümmt sich auf dem Boden, ha ha ha, was für ein guter Gag, wie lustig du doch bist, ich drehe mich in die weibliche Runde, nichts, stille, starre Minen, Blicke auf mich, bewunderung, leichte Bewunderung, ernste Blicke und ich so, okay, ich gehe kurz raus, gehe raus, habe draußen erst mal den ersten Nervenzusammenbruch, weil ich nicht weiss, wie ich aus der Situation rauskommen muss und mache die teuflische Pokerentscheidung, ich erhöhe den Einsatz nochmal, ich treib's noch weiter, um das Ganze nochmal in Wohlgefallen auflösen zu können. All in, all in ist auch dein Lebensmord. All in, natürlich. Das heisst, ich öffne wieder die Tür zur Maske, gehe rein, drehe mich nochmal zum Gang raus um und sage, ja, tun Sie ihm das auf die Pfote, dann sollte das wieder in Ordnung sein. Für mich mittlerweile ein offensichtlicher Hinweis, dass ich komplette Scheisse erzähle. Denn warum sollte ich der Vollidiot, Florentin will, über den sich alle lustig machen, der auch in der Öffentlichkeit das absolut Idioten-Image hat, warum sollte ich wissen, wie man mit einem kranken Hund umgeht und warum sollte ich solche Tipps verteilen? Auch dann, ich drehe mich wieder in die Runde, denke, jetzt kommt mein heroischer Eintritt in den Raum, ich trete ein, die Damen liegen mir zu Füssen, beklatschen meinen Triumph, ich drehe mich wieder in die Runde und wieder nichts, null, sie führen auch kein Gespräch, sie sind auch nicht abgelenkt, sie haben das in vollem Ummaß mitbekommen. Sie fangen schon an zu applaudieren oder so. Sie haben das auch in vollem Ummaß mitbekommen. Und ich sag mal, ich möchte mich jetzt nicht allzu sehr in meiner Genialität sonnen, aber ich glaube, dass wenn ich gewisse Dinge, die nicht stimmt, rüberbringen möchte, mir das auch zu einem gewissen Authentizitätsgrad gelingt. Und deswegen haben die das einfach komplett geglaubt. Alle. Auch die Maske, der ich hier die Teil- und auch Hauptschuld gebe, weil diese Person kennt mich schon relativ lange und weiß, dass ich eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur Scheiße erzähle und dass ich selbst sie überzeugen konnte, irritiert mich bis heute, aber anscheinend ist es mir gelungen und dann stehe ich da, weiss nicht, was ich sagen soll, Joyce bemerkt diese Stille und fragt, ach, und du kümmerst dich um Hunde oder wie? Und tut das, ich weiß nicht, schaut euch mal, wenn ihr Joyce nicht kennt, schaut euch mal ein Bild von Joyce im Internet an und stellt euch vor, wie dieses zarte Geschöpf auf dem Sofa sitzt und von unten einen anschaut, mit grossen, wunderschönen, zu Tränen gerührten Augen und dich ernsthaft fragt, du kümmerst dich um Tiere? Und ich meine, was soll ich denn sagen, ausser, ja, naja, gut, das ist jetzt keine grosse Sache, ist mir auch ein bisschen unangenehm, dass das jetzt hier so, naja, nein, es ist nur eine ganz kleine Sache und so. Und dann, ach so, dann mit dem Tierheim oder so. Und dann musst du natürlich einfach noch weiter all in gehen. Das ist das Problem an all in, dass du noch weiter gehen musst und du sagst, ja, in Berlin, da gibt es einige Strassenhunde und die Tierheime sind ja total überfüllt. Ich dachte mir spätestens ab dem Moment, ich komme da nicht mehr raus und ich muss da einfach irgendwie nur noch durch die Story durchkommen. Und vor allem dann, erst dann ist mir eingefallen, dass meine Geschichte sehr viele Lücken hat, dass ich wirklich grosse Lücken in der Geschichte habe, weil Neomagazin wird in Köln aufgenommen, ich wohne in Berlin und dann sage ich, ja, in Berlin gibt es ja, die Tierheime sind ja komplett überfüllt und ich habe da mal einen Strassenhund mal kurzzeitig bei mir aufgenommen und so und dann sie, ach, in Berlin gibt es Strassenhunde, ja, ja, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt und dann so, aha, und warum ist sie dann in Köln und erst in dem Moment so, das ist eine verdammt, verdammt gute Frage und dann so, aha, und warum ist sie dann in Köln? Und erst in dem Moment so, das ist eine verdammt, verdammt gute Frage. Und dann ich wirklich mit einem Geistesblitz gesegnet so, ja, ja, nein, ich habe dann den Strassengund weitervermittelt an eine Besitzerin in Köln, ja. Und die natürlich fünf Minuten vor Aufzeichnung von Neo Magazin in die Redaktionsräume hineinkommt und mit mir über diesen Hund spricht. Völlig klar, obwohl ich in Berlin wohne. Und auf jeden Fall dann auch alles, ja klar, und ja, Joyce weiter, ja, ich setze mich ja auch persönlich total für Hunde ein, und ich war ja letztens in Portugal, und da gibt es ganz furchtbare Tötungszentren, und ich musste einfach lachen bei dem Wort Tötungszentrum, weil ich das, ich finde das einfach einen sehr guten Namen. Ich mag auch, also ich stelle mir da einfach eine portugiesische Weltsicht vor, die ja, wir bringen Strassenhunde um, aber anstatt, wie man das in Deutschland vielleicht machen würde, dass eine, vielleicht eine, keine Ahnung, Wildtierbegrenzungseinrichtung, Behörde zu nennen oder irgendeinen neutralen Namen, heisst das einfach Tötungszentrum. Knallhart, einfach ohne Bullshit, ohne bürokratisches Hin und Her. Wir töten Tiere, das ist ein Tötungszentrum. Und unter dem Gesichtspunkt muss ich einfach lachen, weil das einfach so die Bösen, weil es ist, wie wenn du einen schlechten Fantasy-Roman schreibst und der Böse heisst irgendwie Der Leichenschänder von Morsul oder so, wo du denkst, kein Mensch würde sich so nennen. Auf jeden Fall muss ich lachen und dann sehe auch wirklich mit todesernster Miene, da gibt es überhaupt nichts zu lachen. Das sind ganz furchtbare Umstände, die da unten herrschen und ich so, ja, ja, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, das ist bestimmt ganz furchtbar und ja, ja. Und also das war ganz furchtbar, und vor allem auch die Maske und die Kostümdame, also drei, sag ich mal drei überdurchschnittlich hübsche Frauen sitzen mir gegenüber, schauen mich nickend an und ach du bist echt ein toller Typ und ich kann ich kann diese Schmeichelung überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen, weil ich wirklich Todesängste habe, wenn das hier, wenn das jetzt auffliegt, dann stehe ich wirklich wie das grösstmöglich denkbare Arschloch da. Nicht nur habe ich Joyce angelogen und wollte im guten Licht stehen, nein, ich habe diese Lüge auch noch durchgezogen bis zum bitteren Ende. Wir kommen sowas von in die Hölle, aber mal ganz im Ernst, also dann ist Joyce doch jetzt nicht die Hellste. Naja, also das ist mir tatsächlich auch erst dann aufgefallen. Ich dachte, weil ich, die macht ja so einigermaßen lustige, also ein bisschen politisch korrekt, einigermaßen lustige Videos auf YouTube. Und ich denke mir, wer sich, also sag ich mal, in einem, sag ich mal, berufstätig ähnlichem Umfeld mit Humor beschäftigt, gehe ich einfach generell davon aus, dass er ein gewisses Gespür für Komik hat und da einfach auch dahinter steigen kann, was das gerade für eine unangenehende Situation ist. Auf jeden Fall habe ich unserem Kollegen, habe ich auch noch, als ich draußen war, gesagt, warte weitere fünf Minuten, komm nochmal rein und sag, ja die Waisenkinder sind jetzt da und wollen sich für die Spenden bedanken. Und ich denk einfach nur dran und gucke auf die Uhr und denke mir, fuck ey, wenn der jetzt gleich reinkommt und das sagt, ich kann das nicht. Mein wichtiges Szenario, man spendet an Waisenhaus und natürlich kommen die Waisenkinder fünf Minuten vor Aufzeichnung an den Arbeitsplatz der betreffenden Person, um sich zu bedanken. Das heisst, ich Tür auf, Sturm raus, sag ihm erstmal, komm auf gar keinen Fall nochmal rein, komm wieder rein und oh Gott ey, das war echt, und vor allem dann noch in dem Raum zu sein mit ihr, war so, ich habe mich so schlecht gefühlt, weil ich dachte mir, ich stehe gerade völlig zu Unrecht in einem sehr guten Licht da, weil auch dieser instinktive Reflex, das so ein bisschen runterzuspielen, war ja völlig richtig, zu sagen so, naja, das ist ja nichts grosses und nein, das ist ja völlig richtig, das passt ja perfekt in dieses Bild des Wohltäters, der na, ich will gar nicht, dass ihr das jetzt wisst und nur weil jemand anderes reinkommt und es benennt, muss darüber gesprochen werden. Es zeigt einem doch, dass es sehr einfach ist zu lügen, wenn man gar nicht die Absicht hat zu lügen. Ja, absolut. Entweder du hast grandios gespielt oder so richtig overperformed, dass es so wirklich so overkam. Oder es war einfach nur ein bisschen dämlich und leichtgläubig, was ich ja glaube. Ja, es ist ja, sie kennt mich ja überhaupt nicht. Und da ist es natürlich auch schwer, glaube ich, festzustellen, ob jemand lügt beim ersten Zusammentreffen. Klar, also das sind für mich allein schon Sätze, wenn die zu mir jemand sagt, ich kümmere mich am Wochenende um Strassenhunde, da lache ich sofort, ohne überhaupt nachzudenken, wer das gerade ist, weil das für mich so absurd ist, die Vorstellung, dass das jemand macht und es dann auch noch sagt und jemandem aktiv erzählt, ich kümmere mich und das auch noch vor einer zu beeindruckenden Frau, also das ist für mich so offensichtlich Bullshit. Aber gut, nicht jeder denkt so, aber das war wirklich extrem unangenehm und ich musste es dann tatsächlich auch der Maskendame dann gestehen, während Joyce noch im Raum war, aber sie hat es nicht gehört und sie auch aus allen Wolken gefallen, so war es krass und sie meinte, sie musste sich auch total das Lachen verkneifen im weiteren Verlauf der Aufzeichnung. Aber Joyce weiss es bis heute nicht. Und Joyce, solltest du das jetzt hören über irgendeinen Soundcloud-Byte, den irgendein böswilliger Zuschauer hier rausgeschnitten hat und dir geschickt hat? Mach dir keine Angst, Leute. Es tut mir wirklich leid, es war nicht böse gemeint. Ich wollte dich nur durch Humor beeindrucken und habe dich dann durch Wohltätigkeit beeindruckt und möchte dich nun weiter durch Ehrlichkeit beeindrucken. Das sind drei Dinge, die dich unglaublich beeindrucken müssen. Und vielleicht, Joyce, gibst du mir noch eine Chance, dass ich das alles wieder gut mache, in einem kühlen Bart. Liebe Zuschauer, sind Sie auch der Meinung, dass das die beste Geschichte war, die Sie jemals gehört haben? Dann schreiben Sie es in die Kommentare. Wir sind auch schon wieder durch, Florentin, wir haben eine Stunde gelabert. Ich fühle mich richtig schlecht, du hast das jetzt jetzt diese ganze, das ganze schlechte Gewissen wieder hochgeholt in mir. Aber es war einfach eine unfassbar lustige Geschichte und du brauchst kein schlechtes Gewissen haben, die Schuld liegt glaube ich nicht bei dir bei dir. Also schon. Ich meine, die Grundidee ist schon sehr veraltet und ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auch unbedingt immer so ankam, wie du erzählt hast. Sie war einfach wahnsinnig dänend. Ja, vor allem, also wer die Neo-Magazin-Folge kennt mit Joyce, zur Not schaut sie euch einfach nochmal an, während Joyce live auftritt, sitze ich ja im Publikum und spiele so den verzweifelten Romantiker, der versucht, sie zu betören und hat dann Pralinen dabei und hat mich schön gemacht und so. Und allein dieser Auftritt wird auch einfach so creepy, wenn sie davor nicht versteht, dass das alles nur ein Witz ist, dass ich nicht wirklich in sie verliebt bin und einfach nur diese Figur spiele. Und was sie für ein Bild von mir haben muss, weil vielleicht hat sie das auch jetzt nicht hundertprozentig als haha, wir machen uns darüber lustig, dass der fette, hässliche Typ auf die wunderschöne Gastfrau steht, das als Gag, sondern sie hat das ja überhaupt nicht verstanden und hat vielleicht, fand mich wirklich sympathisch. Als wirklichen Glauben. Also für so dumme halte ich sie dann doch nicht, also halte ich sie überhaupt nicht, aber vor allem das muss so creepy gewesen sein, weil sie hat ja auch ihre Reaktion. Man kann sich das ja mit dem Wissen nochmal den Auftritt anschauen. Sie hat, glaube ich, jetzt auch nicht so reagiert, so haha, ja, okay, hier, lustig, lustig, sondern eher so ein bisschen so, was will denn der Typ von mir? Also glaube ich nicht hundertprozentig umrissen, wie das gemeint sein soll. Und das war eigentlich noch schlimmer, wie ich da im Publikum saß und wusste, das wird in die Hose gehen. Was ich ja in diesem Auftritt auch so creepy finde, die meisten Leute sagen ja immer, bei jedem Scheiss regen sich die Leute auf und sagen, oh, das ist alles von unserem GEZ-Geld bezahlt, dafür zahle ich nicht gern, dafür zahle ich, will ich gar nicht mehr zahlen und die Leute wissen ja nicht, dass du immer montags da bist bei unseren Reaktionskonferenzen, um Input zu liefern, mit deiner Expertise und Rat und Tat und weiter zu stehen. Und dann bleibst du halt nur bis Mittwoch, wird dein Aufenthalt verlängert, wenn du in der Sendung bist. Und du bist quasi nur wegen diesen beschissenen zweimal, es waren drei Auftritte geplant, du warst nur zweimal zu sehen im Endeffekt im On, mit einem scheißen Luftballon und mit der Pralinenpackung. Und du warst zweimal zu sehen und für diese zwei Zehntelsekunden hast du quasi zwei Tage länger noch übernachtet. Ja, absolut. Was das denn die Bürtenzahler gekostet hat. Und ich habe meinen Zug verpasst. Ich musste dann extra noch mit dem Nachtzug nach Hause fahren, weil die Aufzeichnung ein bisschen länger gedauert hat als geplant. Also das war katastrophal. Das ist eine verschwenderische Sendung. Ja, und vor allem, ich bin ja dann gegangen, ich musste dann sofort weg, weil ich meinen Zug wollte und habe mich dann so halb von Joyce verabschiedet und wollte auch da nochmal so einen Gag reißen, ne, so eine halbe Entschuldigung, halb Gag, ich lerne es einfach nicht und wollte dann so sagen so, ich hoffe, es war okay für dich, so im Sinne von, ne, also wenn man irgendwie so einen kleinen Prank startet auf dem Gast, danach nochmal zu sagen so, hey, ich hoffe, das war jetzt nicht unangenehm für dich irgendwie, weil es ja schon eine unangenehme Situation, wenn jemand dir auch nur im Spiel so irgendwie einen Annäherungsversuch darstellt. So, ich hoffe, es war cool für dich, ich hoffe, es hat dir auch Spaß gemacht und so. Und habe ihr das so halb gesagt, so, ja, ich hoffe, es war dir nicht unangenehm, ich meine, vielleicht können wir und dann im Gehmoment fragt irgendein anderer, hey Joyce, kann ich ein Autogramm von dir haben? Sie dreht sich weg, ich denke mir, okay, das dauert lange, ich muss einfach weg, gehe und wollte dann noch so eine Halbverabschiedung, Halbumarmung, Halb, ich gehe jetzt, ne, ganz unangenehm und sie guckt mich nur so völlig unverständlich an und hä und was und ich gehe direkt und es war so unangenehm. Also dieses ich habe noch nie mit jemandem das verkorktestetreffen ich habe noch nie mit jemandem so schlecht connected wie mit dieser person und es tut mir echt leid weil ich glaube wir hätten es echt ganz gut verstehen können aber es ist einfach so es startet auf dem falschen fuß endet auf dem falschen fuß ist einfach von vorne bis hinten furchtbar und was diese frau für ein bild von mir haben muss, ich weiss es echt nicht, weil das war echt so strange. Und dann habe ich meinen Zug verpasst, ich bin nochmal zurückgefahren, dachte, sie ist vielleicht noch backstage unterwegs, wollte mich nochmal entschuldigen und da war sie auch schon weg. Und ich hatte keine Chance, mir alles ins rechte Licht zu rücken. Jetzt ist vielleicht die Geschichte ganz offenbar und Joyce, falls du das hören solltest, kannst du vielleicht verstehen, dass es nicht so geplant war und es tut mir leid und ich bewundere dich wirklich, ich finde das, was du auf YouTube machst wirklich grandios, ich verfolge dich schon lange und... Ach komm, ja, so, das war das Podcast. Also Lobesystem müssen wir jetzt nicht hier, wir müssen keine Crossbow machen. Glaube ich. Oh, hörst du schon die Musik? Hörst du schon die Outro-Musik?
Ja, ich höre schon die Musik.
Macht's gut!
Ich wünsche euch einen guten Rutsch, das ganze Podcast-Ufoteam.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten Rutsch.
Ja, bis dann, macht's gut.
Tschüss, tschüss.